en l'honneur de la grâce beauté
le charme et le poison de la femme brésilienne
tropical
Je vis
dans un pays tropical
Béni par Dieu
il y a du carnaval dans le carnaval il y a des œufs que le
guitare, je suis Flamengo, j'ai un déni
appelé Thérèse
Je vis
dans un pays tropical
Béni par Dieu
par nature
il y a du carnaval dans le carnaval
Je suis Flamengo, j'ai un appel négatif
Thérèse
Je ne suis peut-être pas un baiser de Dieu parce que c'est le cas
mais à la maison tous mes amis
les petits camarades me respectent parce que c'est
est la raison de la sympathie du Pouvoir de quelque chose
plus et joie
où je vis
dans un pays tropical
Béni par Dieu
et beau par nature pour recevoir
il y a le carnaval
Carnaval
Je m'appelle Flamengo, j'ai un rappel
Teresa, je suis Flamengo
dans un patropi
béni
Beau
quelle beauté en février
en février il y a du karma ouais
personne n'a vu que je suis la planète
de Flamengo il y a une fille qui s'appelle Teresa
Flamengo a une fille nommée Terezinha
Je m'appelle Flamengo et je ne traite personne
mais pas toujours brésilien
Flamengo a une fille appelée Tereza